man I wish I was like crafty and knew
how to make stuff because I'm gonna
cosplay Scorpius so bad I can almost
taste it I didn't think I was gonna be
doing this I had expected not to get
this out until next week but I didn't
realize it was only seven episodes
episodes come on
shear us using - it's out binge it in
one night
and I really enjoyed it I really love
this show and it's funny like the few
things that I remember not completely
working for me from the first season I'm
not sure they actually got better but
they stopped bugging me like the the big
one off the top my head is entrapped as
voice annoyed me in season one doesn't
bother me now maybe I just got used to
it no maybe they actually like fine to
know a little bit made it slightly less
grating on like a Steve Urkel kind of
kind of wavelength but they very well
might not have but I love I love these
characters so much I mean like and like
the characters that I love are they
remain amazing I mean my favorites
easily are catcher and Scorpia both
individually and separately and look I'm
just gonna jump all over the place
talking about this I'll avoid talking
specific episode events or spoilers
until a little bit later in the review
and I'll give you a heads up before I
get there but like short version I
really loved the first season I really
loved the second season I'm not gonna
say this one's necessarily better it I
mean obviously it's shorter which is a
little bit annoying and it doesn't it
doesn't really have a proper climax the
way that the first season does either I
do have to wonder if given that the
first season was 13 episode this is only
7 I do have to wonder if they took what
would have otherwise been a full season
I like
breaking it up kinda mean like there's
at the time of my recording nothing's
been announced it's not like they said
we're gonna release season two in two
chunks so like I'm wondering if what
would have been season two is gonna
become seasons two and three because
what Noelle Stevenson said around the
time the first season came out was that
she had four arcs at 13 episodes of
piece worked out so like story lines
aren't that for the most part at least
at least they have a plan for where this
is all going so they could be stretching
it out and as far as overall structure
goes I think they do a really good
balance of sort of the the serialized
this is this season is less serialized
than the first season it is less of each
episode builds directly on the last
because first season kind of had you
since it was establishing all this stuff
and you know every every episode built
on the information that was provided in
the previous ones or the characters that
were introduced in the previous ones not
a ton of new characters introduced in
this one mostly it is us you know
getting to see the characters we already
know do cool or funny or endearing
things or we learn a little bit more
about some of the characters that we
already knew that maybe we didn't know
so much about them before we learn a
little bit more about shadow Weaver we
learn a little bit more about Hordak we
learn a little bit more about beau so
there's a mix of all that going on not
all that many new characters though so
it allows this season to be a bit more
episodic you could actually probably
watch the episodes out of order and it
would make about as much sense there is
still sort of stuff taking over that is
going on in the background that is a bit
of a continuing storyline but that's not
the main thrust of the episodes each
individual episode is a bit more
standalone this time and under other
circumstances I might have complained
about that I'm okay with it here because
I feel like they they didn't do it as an
excuse to not have a continuing story it
was a way of of letting us just sort of
dwell
the dynamics of these characters or get
to know some of them better in some
cases so like I don't necessarily want
the more episodic nature to become the
standard I think overall I kind of like
the more serialized focus a bit more but
for a short season 7 episode slightly
more episodic no I'm cool with it for
this I just I don't want it to be the
new normal if the show gets more seasons
but like that'll be something for down
the line some other highlight characters
that there's there's a number of
characters who really only get
highlighted in one episode but still are
kind of great Seahawk has a gets shows
up for one episode he's great swift to
wind gets gets pretty he shows up he's
in a couple of episode but he gets a
pretty strong highlight I think it's in
the third episode like in and I've Swift
wins great I really do like I like all
these characters they are all great like
there is not a single one of these
characters who I don't enjoy I enjoy
spending time with them because if
they're not just cool they're endearing
if they're not endearing they're
intriguing you know that there's always
something there with each of these
characters for me to enjoy including
some of like look like the miner horde
characters are back like Kyle oh god
poor Kyle so I really enjoyed all of
that and like to put a quick spotlight
on Scorpia I like I got nervous for a
hot second cuz there's there's an
episode that it almost feels like
they're over playing how dumb she is
because she is kind of dumb but I feel
like that same episode bounces it
because she gets into a fight and kind
of kicks the butt of a couple of major
characters and only gets beaten because
she gets outnumbered so like a sapper
says all right that's why she's
dangerous it's not that she's clever
it's that she can she can kick some
serious butt when she needs to like oh
good I look I'm not I'm not gonna lie
I'm pretty sure I audibly squeeze
the first time and it's in the fur it's
in it's within two and a half minutes
they of the first episode when katsu
said hey Dora and especially given that
when that happened like she says it she
like flips over Dora holds her hand says
hey door and then twists her wrists
around into like a wrist lock it's like
oh yes and this season does a bit more
exploration and theming with lgbtq+
characters and themes some of which I
can't really get into without getting
into spoilers but the it is there in
some interesting ways in some cases very
overtly in some other ways like in
interesting almost subversive ways which
I'll try to remember to come back to I
don't think there was anything in the
season that had quite the same level of
of emotional impact on me as say
princess prom and and the second to last
episode the one with the flashbacks to
young catcher and Dora from the first
season I don't think anything the season
hits me quite hard that emotion but
there were a few moments that I got I
got a little bit like oh like there's
some good feels here there's a moment
where a Dora kind of kind of freaks out
a little because they're trying to plan
an attack and actually this is a really
great episode anyways because it's it's
um that they're trying to go through all
these plans on how they're going to to
try and launch this TAC and all the
different you know friends and the
princesses they're they all have their
different ideas of how to do it and it's
almost played like uh like a D&D session
like somebody's even got a DM board well
why did this plan plan fail well you did
you didn't do a investigation check so
you didn't know what was going like like
little things like that but as it builds
and like people are stepping on each
other's toes and like what should or
shouldn't be the plan adora kind of
cracks and says look this has to be
right this has to be perfect because if
it's not perfect
I'm not perfect then things could go
wrong and I could lose all of you and
that that one it was it was fine cuz
that's it's actually a very funny
episode but then that moment came at
like all of a sudden I got this little
okay and like I haven't given a spoiler
warning yet cuz like this is this is a
beat this is a moment this isn't like a
major plot spoiler but like they gave me
a little because you know I'm I'm not a
perfectionist by nature but I am someone
who has a tendency to zero in and
immediately identify all the ways that
something can go wrong so huh
that moment kind of caught me a little
bit there's a moment that I was I was
surprised caught me again like caught me
off-guard out of nowhere which I like I
love I love when something like can like
emotionally just kind of jump me in an
alley I don't know where that that
metaphor came from but there it is and
like there's there's a point of which
Scorpia decides they need to retreat and
she grabs Katra and starts running and
Katra is it doesn't want her to and like
yells at her like what do you think
you're doing and she looks up at Skorpio
and like stops like Skorpio keep strong
but catch it just like stops berating
her just doesn't because she sees the
determination of scorpy's facing and the
worry and the concern and casually just
like Oh yelling at you is the wrong
response right now and something about
that moment gave me a little like and
like there's there's some really see I
I'm not gonna say that I shipped Katra
and Scorpia because I know catcher
doesn't appreciate or god I I have a
whole video about how the fact that I'm
not a shipwreck it's there a little bit
with this show for me
okay I'm not completely immune to it but
like I know catcher doesn't appreciate
her but I love Scorpius so much
and it's and funnily enough this show
doesn't play that off as that dynamic
off is adorable it acknowledges that
this is abusive in a way and so there's
a there's a really great level of
self-awareness with a lot of the stuff
that's going on and I'm gonna now start
to get into spoilers because I want to
talk about the one other moment that got
me to choke up a little bit and I do
feel like this is a bit more of a
spoiler because this was one of the few
instances of brand new characters being
introduced so this I'm talking about the
very last episode here all right here we
go we get to me Bo's dads which first of
all I love how casually it's done
I like his dad's anyway they're kind of
adorable or adorkable might be better
[ __ ] heard one of them has as a first
one's tattoo but you know that they they
use translations and they're still
trying to sort out this language but of
course the door can just read it because
she Shira and one of the masks hers like
what does this say she'll accept it goes
lunch oh I thought it said love so like
little moments like that at his and his
husband's just starts laughing like this
is the best thing ever and it's so funny
but the it wasn't just the appearance of
them that got me a little bit choked up
I just thought they were adorable but
what got me choked up and this comes
back to what I said before with how some
of the lgbtq+ themes almost kind of
subvert things in an interesting way
which is that Boh
his dad's don't know that he's with the
rebellion they think he's at a boarding
school and they don't like the rebellion
they don't like the princesses they want
no part of the violence so he has been
hiding this from them and what they
wanted for him and what they've pictured
for him for his life is not what he
wants and he has not been able to tell
them that
you know he's tried but hasn't been able
to but hasn't felt like they would be
receptive to it so he gave up trying and
when they realized what it is that's
going on with him that conversation is
really wonderful because it's very much
it's very much coded as a coming out
conversation with your parents but it's
with somebody who went to pursue what
are generally sort of in fiction at
least coded as almost a straight
masculine ideal he's a soldier I mean he
even says that word and he comes out as
a soldier to his two dads who realized
that oh my gosh we we were trying to
help and we we were awful and we didn't
even realize it and he says you know I
thought you wouldn't be ok with this you
know you you hate the rebellion I
thought you would hate me and one of his
dad's puts his hand on the shoulder and
says I will never hate you I don't
understand this but I love you and what
I love about this is by by having it be
you know a gay couple that he's having
this conversation with but still coding
it in a way that the general societal
acceptance and certainly fictional
depictions would be that this would be a
like a gay theater kid coming out to his
straight you know Jacques family but
they completely flipped that but that
dynamic stays the same and I think that
that it was a really brilliant thing to
do because it as much as this experience
is I think a bit more common among the
lgbtq+ community it's still a universal
experience
anyone can have this experience of
having to explain to your parents that
you're not what they thought you were or
you're not gonna be what they thought
you were gonna be and maybe you're gonna
be something they actively don't like
they've told you they don't like this
but that's you and it doesn't make it a
straight people get this wrong about
queer people it's a parent's can get
this wrong about their kids it makes it
more universal it makes it more for
everyone but again it's still it's still
it's been a bit level cuz of ring so
true but I love coming at it and that
kind of complete reversal angle I
thought that was just brilliant I really
love that and if I wasn't doing a review
of the season as a whole honestly I'd
still probably do a review just
highlighting that moment because that's
that's just really well done and again
what's great about this and the same
happened with in the first season when
we had spinner Ella and Natasha who
showed up and they were a couple
Bost as artists they are nobody goes you
have two dads they're just his dad's
nobody draws attention to it they're
just a couple a really adorable couple
and I love this show and I really love
the energy that Noelle Stevenson has
brought to it I mean I liked her work
well before Shira I loved nimona I liked
lumberjanes and I guess see if there's a
video clip of it it might have it might
have only been a written review but
apparently I feel like this says it all
as far as this element of the show
there was an interview apparently after
the first season came out and somebody
from some publication asked Noelle
Stevenson you know well what was the
significance of at the end of the first
season in the climax all the princesses
you know sort of glowing with energy and
creating a rainbow and she apparently
she just looked at him in completely
deadpan it's the gay agenda and that's
the thing they're just there it's not
subtext it is text it's not danced
around it's made plain but at the same
time I anyone who would call this an
agenda show or a show about being queer
well no there's queer coding all over it
but it's just there the same way that
straight coding is all over most other
entertainment and it's awesome love
these characters love the look love the
feel love the vibe cannot wait until
there's more I don't know when we'll get
an announcement I mean that this came up
this came pretty quick on the heels of
season 1 so I'm gonna be keeping an eye
out because I really like this I love
this show a lot and these days I'm
especially keen on any show that can
give me a solid second season cuz I
lately I've been having so many things
letting me down on later seasons lately
you know Gotham just ended didn't like
the last season Jessica Jones I loved
didn't like this I could seize and you
know I stranger things loved it didn't
like the second season I'm just anything
that can show me that the first season
wasn't a fluke I'm gonna clutch that to
my heart so sheer on the princesses of
power season 2 it's too short but um how
what are your thoughts on it whatever
they are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it and a whole
bunch of things to do buttons links link
to the patreon which would be
amazing if you could check that out
consider supporting me even me even a
dollar in the a month like helps
seriously
and then other links besides I've gotten
merch I've got new merch if you like
actually click on the teespring link and
like go to go to the storefront plus
other stuff down there site click on it
and see the places that it takes you or
don't you don't have to because at the
end of the day you're the counselor I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]